es ist der winter alptraum aller
autofahrer plötzlich stillstand auf der
autobahn
gefangen im eigenen auto in weißen der
kälte und dunkelheit diesen horror
erlebten in der nacht etliche menschen
auf der autobahn 2 in
nordrhein-westfalen der durch heftigen
schneefall ausgelöste dabei bielefeld
löste sich auch bis zum frühen
dienstagmorgen nicht auf wir befinden
uns hier auf der a2 bei bielefeld und
man kann sagen hier geht nichts mehr
aktuell ist ein etwa 70 kilometer langer
rückstau von bielefeld bis an die
niedersachsen grenze hier sind menschen
wirklich am rande ihrer verzweiflung es
wir haben mit einigen menschen
gesprochen
sie haben uns berichtet dass sie hunger
haben dass sie durst haben dass ihnen
kalt ist sie stehen mit ihren pkws wie
gesagt im stau haben kein sprit mehr
teilweise wissen auch nicht wie es
weitergeht es gibt keinerlei
informationen aktuell der fahrer eines
abschleppwagens schätzt die situation am
frühen morgen so ein
tatsächlich verheerend es ist immer noch
eine geschlossene schneedecke unter den
schnee herscheid die rettungsgassen sind
nicht gebildet und im weiteren verlauf
der autobahn stehen die lkw nach wie vor
quer
die kommen da auch nicht weg weil der
räumdienst nicht durchkommt kommt der
räumdienst nicht durchkommt die schnelle
fahrzeuge nicht durch fahrer und
mitfahrende verbrachten bei minus zwölf
grad die ganze nacht und teils mehr als
zwölf stunden in ihren festsitzenden
fahrzeugen ja es läuft ist jetzt auch
kein winterdienst hier sehen wir hier
stehe jetzt im moment zehn minuten habe
ich stand der forschung hinter fulda bis
kaffee stand ich zehn stunden eine
vollsperrung stunde da hierfür person da
kein essen keine tanke alles kalt guck
mal was wir haben diese aber
30 lief was machen die autobahn ist in
beide fahrtrichtungen gesperrt worden
nachdem lastwagen schon am montagmittag
wegen des schnees stecken geblieben
waren mittlerweile fließt der verkehr in
einzelnen bereichen ab die lage bleibt
aber insgesamt angespannt